[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24
marinada sardina con nosotros en el
estudio Marina bienvenida buena mañana y
vamos a hablar de una polémica que se
está dando en España desde que desde que
los dirigentes del partido de
ultraderecha Box en la comunidad
Autónoma de Castilla y león anunciarse
una serie de medidas antiabortivas en
esa región de qué se trata Buenos días
Raúl exactamente el vicepresidente de la
junta de Castilla y león esta región en
España Juan García Gallardo que
pertenece al partido transnacionalista
ultraderechista vox anunció una serie de
medidas antiabortistas pactadas
supuestamente con el gobierno del PP que
es el que gobierna en esta región en el
que imponen unas medidas para restringir
el derecho al aborto Como por ejemplo
que los médicos deben ofrecer a las
mujeres una ecografía 4d a las mujeres
que quieren Acceder al aborto también
que deben escuchar el latido del feto
para antes de tomar esta decisión esto
se asemeja mucho a políticas que han
tenido gobiernos también
ultraderechistas como Hungría y también
a gobiernos y a países que tiene unas
leyes restrictivas Como por ejemplo
Polonia y Malta para hablar precisamente
de este tema está con nosotras almudena
Rodríguez ella responsable de incidencia
política de la organización catalana
asociación peltre sexual y reproductivos
bienvenida France 24 almudena Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotras quería
preguntarte estas medidas que ha
planteado vox y que están generando
mucha polémica en España para realmente
cambiarían la percepción o el acceso al
aborto de estas mujeres cuando ya
quieren tomar esta decisión este
escuchar el latido del feto o una
radiografía visualizar una radiografía
4d que no es necesaria en los primeros
trimestres del embarazo
Bueno realmente esta medida no va a
cambiar la opinión de una mujer o de una
persona con capacidad cuando ha decidido
interrumpir voluntariamente su embarazo
es decir lo que va a provocar es que las
mujeres busquen vías alternativas para
poder llevar a cabo esa decisión y para
poder abortar en estamos hablando de que
se incrementarían el número de abortos
clandestinos fuera del sistema no es lo
que va Lo que va a determinar en esta
medida en el peor de los casos abortos
clandestinos sin acompañamiento de
profesionales sanitarios con riesgos
para la salud y por tanto abortos
clandestinos y seguros eso es realmente
lo que va a provocar Pero en ningún caso
va a cambiar la decisión de una mujer o
de una persona gestante con capacidad de
gestar que ha decidido poner fin a un
embarazo claro almudena Además del
riesgo añadido que tienen estos abortos
clandestinos o inseguros al no estar
seguidos por un personal público
autorizado para ello también del lado de
la Salud Mental Cómo afecta estas
medidas en el caso de que se implantaran
a la salud de las mujeres a la Salud
Mental de estas mujeres que quieren
hacer un aborto también hay un cierto
chantaje emocional a la hora de acceder
a este derecho y también si le resta
autonomía a las mujeres
Bueno yo creo que cuando hablamos de
Salud Mental está más que demostrado
científicamente que interrumpir el
embarazo no provoca problemas de Salud
Mental es decir lo que provoca problemas
de Salud Mental es precisamente la
infinidad de Barreras en el acceso a
este derecho que enfrentan las mujeres
cuando deciden poner fin a un embarazo
esta medida viene a incrementar esas
barreras de una manera brutal de una
manera discriminada y y por lo tanto lo
que va a hacer es que las mujeres como
decíamos se van a ver abocadas abortos
clandestinos se van a ver abocadas a
desplazarse a otros territorios se van a
buscar abocadas a otras alternativas
mucho menos seguras y que eso sí provoca
riesgos en la Salud Mental pero
interrumpir el embarazo nunca si es
hecho de manera de calidad acompañada
con servicios profesionales sanitarios
profesionales que saben cómo llevar a
cabo una interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo eso Ninguno de los casos
provoca nunca problemas de Salud Mental
almudena la saluda Raúl blanco Gracias
por estar con nosotros en este espacio
de directo América un gusto en España
desde la entrada en vigor de la Ley
Orgánica 12 de 2010 de la salud sexual y
reproductiva de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo de que estamos
hablando se permite el aborto libre
digamos hasta las 14 semanas Y a partir
de esas semanas dependiendo algunas
circunstancias siempre que existan
algunas condiciones no Cuáles son
algunas de estas condiciones de esta
regla
claro lo que la ley española de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
establece es como bien decía Raúl es de
manera Libre hasta la semana número 14
ahí se respeta la decisión de la mujer
por encima de todo y se puede abortar de
manera libre a partir de la semana 14
qué ocurre se necesita un informe médico
emitido por un profesional sanitario que
indique que esa interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo es necesaria aquí dejamos
espacio libre a la interpretación del
profesional sanitario cuando no debería
de ser así porque los condicionantes
dicen siempre que haya riesgo para la
salud de la madre o la salud del feto en
ese caso puede interrumpirse el embarazo
Pero cuál es la definición de salud la
Ley Orgánica de interrupción
involuntaria del embarazo en España no
define no incorpora una definición de la
salud holística es decir no explícita
que la salud es física y emocional
entonces aquí dejamos margen abrimos
margen a la libre interpretación de cada
profesional sanitario Es cierto que la
mayoría de los casos en España el
profesional sanitario va a incorporar la
salud emocional y por lo tanto va a
emitir un informe satisfactorio donde va
a permitir el embarazo y no habría mayor
Barrera Pero hay otros territorios y
otros profesionales sanitarios que
dependiendo de su ideología o de su
formación o falta de formación por
ejemplo con un enfoque de Derechos
Humanos van a decidir que no hay riesgo
para la salud física no van a tener en
cuenta la emocional Y no van a permitir
ese embarazo
una de las grandes barreras que enfrenta
la ley española
también las leyes la para esta
regulación española la prestación de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
España está dentro de la sanidad pública
pero Hay comunidades que derivan los
abortos a los médicos privados de hecho
en Castilla y león donde está surgiendo
esta polémica solo el 2,31% de los
abortos se realizan en centros públicos
Qué consecuencias tiene esto
Bueno aquí lo que enfrentamos es otra de
las grandes barreras para el acceso al
aborto dentro del Estado español que es
la inequidad territorial es decir Hay
comunidades autónomas donde casi no
existen centros para poder realizar
alguna interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo ni privados ni ni públicos no
existen y por lo tanto Esas mujeres o
personas gestantes siempre van a ser
obligadas a abortos clandestinos no por
ejemplo farmacológicos con la compra de
pastillas a través de internet o a
desplazarse en el mejor de los casos y
tienen recursos económicos desplazarse a
otros territorios como sería por ejemplo
Madrid que es una comunidad cercana a
Castilla León
entonces aquí estamos hablando de
inequidades territoriales es decir
tenemos una Ley orgánica que establece
que el conjunto de las ciudadanas
españolas tenemos derecho al aborto pero
depende de donde habites no de Qué
territorio estés habitando dentro de
dentro de España y Hay comunidades
autónomas y municipios donde desde 2010
no se ha reportado ningún aborto
Simplemente porque no hay los recursos
sanitarios ni los centros para poderlo
llevar a cabo llevar a cabo almudena
aquí en Colombia se despenalizó el
aborto hace un año hemos visto en
América Latina Argentina despenalizo el
aborto México en muchos estados también
están abogando por la despenalización de
este derecho para las mujeres qué crees
que va a pasar en España como
organizaciones Cuál es la deriva que ven
ustedes
bueno nosotras estamos viendo una deriva
que no solo es a nivel español estamos
viendo una deriva a nivel internacional
a pesar de los éxitos latinoamericanos
que bienvenidas y lo celebramos y son
muy buenas noticias pero sí que vemos
una deriva internacional que forma parte
de una ofensiva fundamentalista a las
democracias y a los estados de derecho
en todo el mundo lo hemos visto en el
Estados Unidos con cuando este bueno el
ataque al derecho al aborto el decreto
de inconstitucionalidad del derecho al
aborto en Estados Unidos lo estamos
viendo en Polonia donde prácticamente ya
está prohibido completamente abortar lo
estamos viendo en Hungría lo estamos
viendo en la Italia de Georgia es decir
estamos viendo un incremento de los
partidos de extrema derecha y fascistas
que ya están en las instituciones que
están dentro de nuestros parlamentos de
los congresos que están gobernando en
coalición por ejemplo en España junto
del partido Popular en diferentes
comunidades autonómicas pero están
dentro del parlamento europeo Y como
decía están gobernando estos partidos de
extrema derecha junto con el apoyo de
grupos antiderechos
antifundamentalistas antigénero a nivel
internacional es decir son una
constelación de partidos de extrema
derecha de grupos fundamentalistas de
todas partes del mundo que trabajan de
manera colectiva que están articulados
que tienen muchísimos recursos y muchos
medios para imponer una agenda política
y una agenda económica y esa agenda
política pasa en primer lugar por la
prohibición y la radicación de los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de las
mujeres y de las personas en las que más
este ataque al derecho al aborto que
estamos viendo en Castilla de León no
deja de ser la réplica de esa estrategia
internacional y se ha llevado a cabo con
anterioridad en Estados Unidos en
Polonia en Hungría o en muchísimos otros
sitios